[Music]
maya lin became a household name while
still an undergraduate at yale
university
in 1981 she won a national design
competition for the vietnam veterans
memorial in washington d.c
once controversial it's since been
embraced as a powerfully evocative
tribute to those we lost
she went on to design other acclaimed
works including the civil rights
memorial in montgomery alabama but
unlike those enduring monuments
her latest creation won't be around for
long and instead of a tribute to our
past
it is a warning about our future anthony
mason shows us how it all came to be
deep in the pine barrens of southern new
jersey back in february
what height is that one i mean they're
all in the
35 to 40 arrangement the designer maya
lin
was picking out dying trees i think the
two
just they're just too short
for a public art project aimed at
illuminating the costs
of climate change if we cut him at 40
he might be okay she made it clear she
wanted trees that are in trouble
so we're looking for something that was
it's gonna die
forester bob williams who worked with
lynn
says these atlantic white cedars are
dying on the east coast
because of rising sea levels and
hurricanes
we've got to get the public to better
understand our forest and what's
happening
and this is terrific when did you first
see this idea in your head uh
summer of 2019.
lynn's idea i would like to bring a
ghost forest to manhattan
and in march that's just what she did
the trees trucked into new york could be
no taller than
52 feet so the flatbeds could take the
city's
tight corners the main preparator tom
reedy and i both
lost a lot of sleep going oh yeah we're
going to move
50 foot dead trees to the middle of
manhattan
but late at night they arrived at
madison square park
there are 49 trees and this is how you
mapped it out
i mapped it out but literally
we had to avoid all these lines
electrical lines sewage lines
lynne had modeled the entire project in
her new york studio
i literally had to choose and
re-calibrate
every hole after the first hole because
each tree was in complete dialogue with
its neighbor
and spacing distancing
having mapped this out and studied it
made models do you still get surprised
i'm terrified it's not going to work
every single time
i have nightmares and i never know if
it's going to work
or not well how do you feel about it now
i'm feeling pretty good about it
i think we need to plant everything the
ohio-born
artist and architect has made a lasting
mark on the american landscape
designing the vietnam veterans memorial
in washington
the civil rights memorial in montgomery
alabama
and a series of wave field installations
like this one at the university of
michigan because i'm making them a
little closer and i want to see what
happens
but as lynn was in the final stages of
creating the ghost
forest in late january her husband of
nearly 25 years
daniel wolf died of a sudden heart
attack
you did this during a an especially
trying time
not just for the country but for
yourself
how did you get through it um i'm still
getting through it
yeah and my kids are getting through it
so it's it's you know it's it's very
um it's hard
somehow she went ahead with the project
did that help you in any way yeah
it did working is something that
creativity is a
to me it's a real gift maybe it's
because my dad was
in the arts my mother's a poet but
something that i really
have needed and loved
the 49 trees in the ghost forest will
stand
until the fall slowly graying as the
park
sees the seasons change they're majestic
trees they're beautiful just as a work
of art
they're 50 feet tall they're 8 60 to 80
years old
i'm hoping people are going to go
through and go these
trees are spiritually profound i mean
there's something
really there sometimes i think
haunting and beautiful can move you in a
way
that will hopefully get us to say this
is happening
care enough to do something
myelin has dedicated the ghost forest to
her late husband
now she waits to see what the thousands
who walk through madison square park
every day will make of it what are you
hoping to see
wonder ah maybe some head scratching
hopefully some smiles and hopefully kids
running around
and looking up at the trees and going
wow and i'm hoping people will kind of
find their own favorite tree in the
grove
but they're warning signs too oh
absolutely no it's a wake-up call
inspired by milan's ghost forest in june
madison square park conservancy is
organizing a symposium to explore how
public
art can address climate change and the
exhibition will remain in the park
through november 14th i can't wait to go
but it's striking to see that vibrant
green grass
surrounded so it with the dead trees in
the middle of it right
yeah yep that's crazy sorry i thought
you had more to see
i did but he talked he said it she said
it all
right so you said it you actually said
exactly what i was just the combination
of the two right